ante dos comisiones de investigación del
congreso de perú que era málaga jefe de
los ensayos clínicos de la vacuna
destino farm reveló que el ex presidente
de martín vizcarra le solicitó dos dosis
contra el kobe 19 para él y su esposa en
octubre de 2020 málaga afirmó que
vizcarra fue informado que las
inoculaciones no pertenecían al ensayo
clínico días después el entonces
presidente le solicitó una vacuna para
su hermano el médico dijo que fue una
corrección y que no tuvo ningún cálculo
político respecto a los casi 500
funcionarios vacunadas dijo que ellos
seguía indicaciones sea un oficial de
enlace y no preguntaban nombres sólo se
preocupaban de asegurar la parte médica
al respecto en el parlamento peruano se
han lanzado hasta cuatro denuncias
constitucionales contra martín vizcarra
lo acusan de presuntos ilícitos contra
la administración pública y corrupción
de funcionarios
los congresistas estarían buscando
inhabilitar a vizcarra por 10 años de
toda función pública antes de que se
realicen las elecciones del 11 de abril
en la que vizcarra precisamente postula
al parlamento y en medio de todo esto el
perú busca que su relación de conchi
su principal socio comercial no se vea
afectado por el escándalo conocido como
el vacuna gheit